colocaram um curso
é o senhor absoluto sabe um pouco nada
especial
eu vou tentar ser nunca de mais concreto
e então é e trata uma coisa muito não
quer uma coisa muito clara a proposta de
construção que é esta maneira que nós
temos de olhar próprio território é que
a grafia é de facto a área do
conhecimento que estuda o território
essa palavra que todos pensamos que tudo
temos uma coisa qualquer coisa ser
caríssimo uma panelinha e vascaínos
problemas hoje em dia em portugal
tirando autoestima que tem por sete
centros históricos e algumas coisas das
velhas realidades já apreendidas e quase
conservadas em agora bellucci como como
turismo rural
rhoades e entre essas aldeias típicas e
ea cidade histórica praticamente não há
nada sou dizem que são eo que é ótico o
que é santa maria da feira por exemplo
nós devemos olhar o castelo trovoada de
construções de estradas e auto-estradas
de fábricas e escritórios de tudo isso
que ocupa literalmente município todos
que não corresponde em nada aquela ideia
de cidade ou do campo nós temos na
cabeça e eles que vamos falar
nós temos que ficciona a realidade para
que a realidade nos seja excessiva
não funcionamos a realidade é
completamente surda e muda
e sabemos algo disso como explica que o
estado português que diz que quem sonha
não morte nem o quadro é um mundo
perfeito seria em sua racionalidade mais
racional
por exemplo o campo seria bom para serem
enjoados enfim o céu azul essas coisas e
não é igual a olharmos para mais por
exemplo quando quando vamos deixar nunca
de mais calmos
tivemos aquela coisa negra né e dourada
que ao mesmo tempo nos duros parece um
filme grana e é e depois começámos por
lá né
estamos deslumbrados com aquino não
estamos a ver é um caso isto é olhar
para as coisas e não saber o que elas
representam pouco território basicamente
é uma construção social montanhas e rios
e coisas são coisas que já há muito
tempo quase todas
ações dos territórios na ocupamos são
feitas pela sociedade que nós
pertencemos ao longo do tempo longo do
tempo curto do passado do presente e 7 e
o desafio é então entender isso olhando
pro mata lindo por exemplo a evolução da
população nos últimos dez anos vejam
como está o norte e centro de portugal
tudo que resulta de ser aliás a parte do
país totaliza parceiro sabe e tudo que
são conscientes
são situações onde a população cresce
embora um pouco e vejo uma diferença
impressionante trás os montes é uma
constituição azul de algas passadas não
vivem agricultores a gente melhorou e
esquadro e vê são pessoas têm uma forma
que trabalhando nos serviços navio
exceto agricultura fax de notícia não
chega a 3% do produto e quando tudo o
resto todas as fontes de rendimentos em
97 não podemos dizer que é raro
depois elas pra esse lado é pra nós
temos por aqui e é o tal país urbanos
das cidades estão velocidades nenhuma
delas fossem pontos ou circus no mapa
perfeitamente definidas e distintas do
resto do território não é uma imensa mas
sei quase dava até lá em cima braga e
que mistura tudo e vem do estudo google
vendo isso e um copo o avião nós
facilmente nos damos conta disso
portanto são estes mistérios que nós
temos que resolver a começar por
desconstruir os conceitos tradicionais
da cidade
por exemplo as pessoas pensam que a
cidade pode ser isto
aquela idéia de que uma cidade da europa
é foi durante séculos uma coisa foi
notificada porque a sociedade era muito
complicada ea muralha é uma coisa sem a
qual não havia sinal de que o grupo
estaria enviava se não tivesse esta
defesa e contesta e daí qualquer coisa
dentro de qualquer coisa é uma cidade
a idéia do que a cidade é o interior
está dentro dos limites que em tempos
foram muralhas pode não ser aqui né no
rio de janeiro esta menciona favela
conhecida por complexos ou não e que
combina é vai rolar tata comprou sérico
é uma modalidade de urbanização
infelizmente é mais recorrente no mundo
quando nos dizem assim
sorriso de orelha a orelha sabem que o
estado do mundo vivem citadas de música
cidades onde é conseguir na índia no
brasil na áfrica toda no resto da
américa latina
é no fim de contas a organização da
pobreza e não tem nada a ver com cidades
portuguesas velhas antigas nem com as
fantasias do dubai por exemplo são
coisas completamente distintas
se formos a luanda vemos um emprestado
extremamente denso de coisas que
pertencem a mundos completamente
diferentes prédios completamente
degradados que foram ocupados com a
saída dos planos e foram todos
aproveitados não têm casa tenho tantas
janelas é visto não sabia como ia atrás
arranha-céus do capitalismo global
neste caso domina os pulsos os negócios
do petróleo
portanto é uma confusão nós percebermos
o que é esta identidade urbana de países
chamados pós coloniais ou então coisas
são frescas como alface
como não dá pra ver que é uma
configuração urbana que não tem qualquer
precedente histórico é qualquer coisa
que é filha da auto estrada e
genericamente deixa sair a aprovação que
hoje nós temos e é um compacto de
edifícios e coisas que entre outras
coisas em portugal foi o primeiro a ter
dentro do mesmo edifício com um hospital
e um centro comercial e tanta gente
entra no estacionamento e olha sem
espantar para as setas e ver ultimação
urgência e não quer que a oposição seja
na urgência né e estas coisas podem se
confundir o campo é uma trapalhada
ensinamos que o campeão as campanhas
eleitorais representa essa espécie
anita no campo é uma fotografia de ver
sai do palácio de versalhes a maria
antonieta cria influenciada por roçou
crianças ingressaram campo porque cortez
hora vício
a idéia é que o campo era puro e que os
jovens príncipes deviam ser criados no
campo e pedra e fez um faz de conta e
este faz quando finalmente está na
cabeça das pessoas está em vimioso é os
pombais essas construções muito bonitas
mas em 2011 também ninguém vive da
agricultura portanto é muito difícil
dizer se terá ou não ou às vezes temos
medo por mim paisagística rurais são que
neles no inverno os fotografados de um
copto dissemos que não temos alguma
coisa que era o êxodo rural pessoas
saíram dos campos e que os campos se
modernizaram conseguiu a israel foram
plantações outra técnica tratou a setre
e que depois que tem um terço das
cidades entretanto não é nada é verdade
como vão ver
é muito difícil perceber que isso é uma
pura de culto minha tanto de um lado o
réu que está preso lhe pôr umas coisas e
do outro lado urbano quando se vai
estrear em auto-estradas insistirem
nisso ficam muito com o islã na placa em
88 por que não vão ter a chave para essa
coisa para essa explicação porque temos
mapas antigos do tempo do fundo são as
áreas-chave rural era uma coisa feita de
figuras ocorre que os nossos sentidos
pessoas cruzavam que trabalhavam lá
vamos ter os trajes típicos e e era
assim representar portugal nas cidades
praticamente não ouvia se virmos o outro
mapa ao lado é uma fria produzido pelo
instituto nacional de estatística nos
diz da densidade da população
distribuída pelo país estão a ver aquela
aí nós vamos falei pra norte onde nos
situamos aqui essa era aqui o porto e
vamos gastar mais impressionante que são
praticamente três milhões que fazem um
artefacto urbano de grande dimensão para
o nosso país e como não custou nada é a
imagem tradicional da síria tanto
podemos dizer que a cidade perdeu os
limites para uma forma o centro
esta imagem é fiança em santa maria da
feira e podem ver o que é uma urbanidade
muito comum em portugal
e toda essa mistura de ocupação do solo
que se fosse um biólogo provavelmente
este fosse um animal
diria que é um animal transgênico ou
seja cujo código genético é um conjunto
de é coisa que vem do organismo ser
completamente distintos e esta ideia ter
dificuldade que nós temos em perceber os
organismos transgênicos que nos faz com
que faça uma coisa destas
a gente fica o recado não é que tu manos
mas no campo e na cidade
se eu for atender a questões muito
científicas do gênero
o campo sociológica mente economicamente
é um lugar onde se vive da agricultura
onde a cultura dominante
são as velhas tradições e hoje o aqui um
pensamento muito agarrado aquilo que é
antigo e tetra e que a paisagem uma
espécie de coisa que acho que é
fabricada por que os agricultores que
seriam supostos jardineiros da paisagem
estudo essas coisas ao mesmo tempo é o
campo pois não dá não é isso que
indústrias são necessidade e fumavam e
não sei que depois também não fumei
teremos muitas dificuldades posto no
mapa ou aquela zona industrial i
acontecer amorim que patrocinou a
bicicleta está aqui e nós vemos o que é
isto tudo ea complexidade de futuro e
são essas questões que nós temos que
entender eu entendia quando escrevi este
livro é registrada e essa imagem também
é daqui da estrada próxima da registrada
para mim era o código genético da cidade
a cidade é tudo que é identificação
atividades variadas decidir e de com
infraestrutura asfalto na cidade a
agosto vagens weslley de gás ea estrada
é como se fosse um suporte técnico
nestas coisas se ligam e dizem os
espanhóis e portanto a rua da estrada
era o o oratório mais interessante é
perceber o que é que é uma idéia de
urbanidade enquanto que o outro vida no
campo que apresentou um ganho aqui em
primeiro plano só tem um banho são o
suporte biológico cenários cabras que
são equipadas nas orelhas que você
receber um subsídio se dão leite morre
no impresso e traz é quase 100 metros
então não vai ficar de vilarinho das
furnas
a primeira aula e foi surpreendida por
uma razão eu achei que estava muito bem
esta carta porque quero frisar é essa
confusão que se instalou sobre é essa
idéia campestre dos campos
agora vamos tentar uma explicação vamos
aproveitar esse pastor que é uma espécie
não é um guardador de rebanhos que teria
opção guarda das auto estradas está a
pensar que renovou esta protesto esta
lavoura é uma construção de uma grande
infraestrutura que é uma auto-estrada
que na minha opinião nos dá uma imagem
muito clara de como as coisas se
processam uma autoestrada
são estudantes e os acessos ao túnel do
marão é uma espécie de linha que a
traçada uma coisa abstrata e que a
partir daí passa a ser um ponto de
ficção um ponto de referência mas com
que nenhuma lógica uma ordem por exemplo
andorinhas entendem isto independente
o céu é tudo igual a atmosfera na escola
mas pagou a mais chuva - nuvem mesma
coisa mas assino x e vão elas que têm
tendência para a escrita musical
se não recuarmos muito antigamente
podemos ver coisas muito justas e que
nos parecem muito arcaicas como uma
pomba é assim que se responde às feitas
de pedra então ver que estamos pensando
na graça não é longa história da
humanidade é um é um processo treinar os
lugares evitáveis entanto aquilo que era
um criativo que se no inverno e tauá é
uma coisa que passa a pé e chuto
se continuarmos e nos aproximarmos de
imagens muito pro centers
agora está uma imagem do princípio do
mundo era uma vez um campo onde só havia
terra ervas vinho e esporte setre
praticamente que se podia fazer o
ajudava bastante limitado porque via
entre na altura de uma máquina poderosa
faz uma faz um rasgo no chão e instala
tubos canos fios e aliá não é impossível
entrou magnéticos água e esgoto
eletricidade telecomunicações e partir
daí aquele lugar era tudo que era antes
mas isto quer dizer além do que podia
fazer oa por exemplo vinha antes destas
coisas não me podem fazer essas coisas
porque porque a espécie duas próteses 11
suportes tecnológicos que permitem que
muitas atividades possam funcionar nesse
território
agora vem a questão complicada e eu
tenho andado para essa aqui é quanto
mais intensidade tecnológica houver no
território desde uma rede wireless até
uma rede energética cidade a uma rede de
água e gás
melhor é a mobilidade cuidado falou em
geral é uma unidade das pessoas à mulher
da informação como cuidar das
mercadorias é uma unidade da energia ou
seja transformar
a nova isso e ter móveis os que são
muito móveis
por contraposição 11 por móveis ou seja
aquelas pessoas que limitadas por
questões não têm diploma escolar não tem
dinheiro não tem relações sociais etc
estão bastante limitadas no tipo de
opções que podem tomar o sintero móveis
como os como se diz tão comum das
maiores brigas levantou do lado enquanto
que lisboa só salvar o céu e portanto é
um embora o suporte de sistemas
tecnológicos não estejam igualmente
distribuídas no território na sociedade
a tendência é para que o seu uso cada
vez mais intenso torne é a sociedade
mais móvel e para o território mais
plástico se a suportes mobilidade muito
caros um bom automóvel de luxo outros já
vimos são mais baratos que o ipad em um
show normal e qualquer coisa que pode
estar na mão da pessoa mais pobre que a
campanha não é verdade que o acesso à
tecnologia e aos meios de mobilidade
apenas uma coisa que só quem pode tem
que pensar nessas coisas um dia entra
demonstrada pela o assalto e e ele nunca
mais vai perceber que é feito o mundo ou
que os que pensam que andar a pé é muito
bom
um pai dizia quando crescer caso ele
fosse preso é mais uma perna e na outra
o que pode acontecer não é pode ficar
como diz o povo com as pernas cortadas
em mobilidade até tem as limitações que
têm e são muitas
quando as limitações são muitas acontece
com esta rapariga que é muito conhecida
que é uma detentor do recorde olímpico
sem fim que resolve exatamente com uma
prótese resolver os seus problemas tanto
é que a própria não é só por por uma
função perdida não é muito mais
sofisticado que isso criou novas funções
e novas possibilidades de motricidade e
portanto quando eu falo quando eu digo
que eu vou dizer que é um caso que
mostra uma prótese territorial que
permite uma série de coisas é próprio
não é só para comprar coisas perdidas
após ser solto no sentido em que ela vai
encontrar novas funcionalidades isso que
apertava um jóia no oportunismo de
escolas tecnológicas evolui por camadas
de gelo era uma vez um caminho em praga
o que tinham
luto luto em água por esta fonte quando
vivia onde víamos humanos e os cavalos
atrás havia um instante para lavar a
roupa certa depois que este fechou
porque agora a água nos canos os cavalos
estão dentro dos motores dos carros etc
e fez uma auto estrada por cima
entretanto esta ficou diz funcionar é
branco nesta imagem isso é muito claro
na maior parte das situações não é 100
por exemplo eu escolhi esta imagem para
falar da sociedade enredo é é um missão
é uma estrutura que não têm sempre pode
se conectar em qualquer lado e esta
torre tem 120 metros e alegria em um
jorro parece estar solta tudo está
completamente
temos que aprender reflete muitos obra o
que são as questões particulares são as
questões de relações e que tipo de
facilidade é que elas nos funciona nos
permitem fazer por exemplo dessa relação
entre tecnologia e território em
determinadas tecnologias é muito difícil
ver isto é uma coisa assim central
fundada há 60
sem isto é internet não funcionava e
cláudia a nuvem estava no entanto as
pessoas não só não vê isso com muitas
pensam que a sociedade da informação é
lixo não pensa não pensam que há
relações com tecnologia que são diretas
do gênero estão mestrado este é o meu
automóveis também o telemóvel 200 de
próteses que eu uso para socializar para
ambientar mas depois atrair novas
tecnologias que não tem essa
visibilidade são mais difíceis de
entender
e no entanto são importantes pra acabar
mostrando desta imagem linda eu diria
que tal como as próteses biônicas isso é
uma imagem baseada num raio x numa
própria rotina
portanto a 15 positivo eletrônico clay
as informações do usuário envia para
aquela para a linha traz que por sua vez
está ligado ao nervo ótico que recebe
impulso elétrico
o cérebro e portanto esta prótese
envolvido na humana para uma certa
doença da china para uma figueira
permita esta pessoa descobrir um mundo
completamente distinto não é o nosso
mundo é muito legal aquela pessoa nunca
viu não termina às diferenças que nós
temos nas gravações de ver e tem uma
obsessão do mundo
bom o território e para terminar é um
caso isto quanto mais quanto maior
desculpa e foram intensidade tecnológica
melhor as possibilidades desse
território ser transformado ser
apropriado de formas diferentes e nós
temos que estar preparados para perceber
a dimensão dessa metamorfose
não estamos a acompanhar constantemente
com que o uso do nome que tudo foi que
está tudo estragado pelo isso não é
verdade